my name is heather miller i'm a phd
student at
epfl and i work with martin odersky on
scholar related stuff
i am also at the moment at working with
databricks
does anybody know databricks and spark
do you think it's cool
i think it's cool so i'm currently
with them and actually some of this
stuff that i'm going to talk about
this function passing stuff is sort of a
research project
that i'm doing part of my time when i'm
there um
but uh i want to first say that
sort of what i've been doing for
majority of my phd at this point has
been sort of trying to
provide language support for distributed
system
builders so um you know i've started
with things like serialization so we
made a serialization framework that does
stuff at compile time so it's
more performant than runtime-based
serialization frameworks
at the same time it's flexible you can
add a bunch of serialization for you can
change
the way data your data is represented
and that whole idea there is to
be a little bit flexible in how you
exchange messages between data between
machines and then
most recently i've worked on something
called spores
as a funny name but the idea is
basically
to have some sort of notion of a
function or a
function closure that you can serialize
and send over the wire and you can send
back and forth all over the place if you
feel like it
and this is actually a pretty well
not a super involved problem but more
involved than you might expect
you can actually do all kinds of stuff
like use type signatures to control
how or what what closures capture and
things like this so you can actually
in in apis decide what your what users
who pass functions to you might actually
capture and send over the wire or
something like this
so these are two sort of projects that
i've worked on and actually what i'm
gonna talk about today um
is sort of it builds on the basis of
these serializable functions so
um and the idea and the goal sort of of
this whole work is to
to try and provide some sort of
substrate that one can build a
distributed system upon
uh and and sort of make things a little
bit easier by design
um and actually uh one nice sort of
side effect or not side effect but one
result of
actually side effects aren't so horrible
sometimes but okay you need to do
logging
especially in distributed system i hope
that you know if you're writing a
functional distributed system that
you're doing some kind of logging
because it's otherwise a bad idea
but so what i'd like to sort of show you
at the end of all of this is that
by design if you do things a little bit
more functionally you keep things
stateless and you
you pass functions around to do
transformations then
you know things like fault tolerance
keeping stuff in memory and then also
even debugging if you have types around
you know
get a little bit better a little bit
nicer and like i said in a nice a nice
functional way that's
that's that's stateless as i'll show you
but i also want to point out that this
is currently like a research project
it's something that we're just
experimenting with we have no idea if
it's a great idea a horrible idea if
it's going to work out if it's like
really inflexible if it's too flexible
we're currently experimenting with it so
all of this stuff that i'm going to talk
to you about
this is all under development and you
know can fluctuate
and we're working on actually like
trying to write it up for for for a
conference the next month or two
and again i have to say thanks to
databricks because they're letting me do
this
with them and uh on on spark basically
playing with spark to to realize some of
these things
and okay if you walk away with anything
you should walk away with this one
fundamental idea and that is that
this whole function passing model thing
is basically a dual to
to like message passing via actors
it's it's actually the cool thing is
it's it's a compliment
it's it's it's a duel it kind of just is
the inverse
uh so okay how is it how is it a
complemented dual or whatever
so the idea is in actor systems i mean
the
tat
the short the short sort of description
of of what active frameworks kind of do
uh the actors encapsulate state and
behavior so you have a message handler
that sort of dictates
the stuff that you want to do to data
that you receive and
an actor stays on one machine it doesn't
move around it gets instantiated
somewhere and it should never go
anywhere else and that's very good
actually you should
never want to move your actor anywhere
um and and sort of
the the the big observation is that
actors exchange
data uh through asynchronous messaging
in a concurrent way right
but they they they keep their their
behavior their message handler in one
place and they pass their data around
so the function passing stuff the idea
behind this
is that you have a stateless like
a stateless thing that is passing the
functions around
so it's it's basically you keep your
data
like represented in persistent data
structures
you keep it stationary and you pass the
functions around through asynchronous
messaging
so we don't want to move data you don't
need to serialize data don't serialize a
little
little code pointer to some
functionality that you want to do to
that data
and i think if i want you all to have
the right idea that this is a model for
programming with data not like some new
concurrent process
um i'm not trying to replace a
concurrent process like actors instead
we're just providing a new way
or a new means of working with
distributed data in a more functional
way
so like that's should keep that in mind
has anybody does it has anybody read
this
by the way this paper it's a good one
right like this is from 1994.
um and and so to go back to this point
here
about you know providing a new way to
work with distributed data whenever you
try to develop some new framework for
working with distributed objects
you have to kind of be careful of a
number of pitfalls that that distributed
framework builders or i'm sorry
not framework builders but people who
try to operate on distributed objects
wind up falling into and while we keep
falling into it for now more than 20
years
um as this paper sort of it's it's
timeless it still describes a lot of
mistakes that we currently make and sort
of the big mistake that we currently
that that system uh well that people who
build some frameworks for for
distributed
sort of object passing and whatever what
we often
do is we kind of mess up this notion of
transparency
i'm just going to quote the paper and
explain what i mean
so sort of the the key things that make
something a distributed system latency
like you know memory being in different
address spaces partial failure
and concurrency make sort of the merging
of different computational models like
local and
remote sort of you know objects uh
you know unwise and they just it just
doesn't work
i mean you i can if you read the paper
there's pl i'm not going to name
anything by name so there are plenty of
of of of systems and and and and
protocols and whatnot that they cite
that didn't really do
do the job the best they could because
they ended up being transparent or
trying to be transparent
instead what they say a better is a
better approach is to accept that there
are irreconcilable differences between
local distributing uh distributed
computing
and that one should be conscious of
those differences at all stages of the
design and implementation of a
distributed application that means
that somebody like you know if you have
a whole like
like you know sandwich of different
users who are trying to build something
that should be talking to
different machines all users should be
aware of latency all users should be
aware of
of communication and some of these
things you should not try to be
transparent
so rather than trying to merge local and
remote objects engineers need to
constantly be reminded of the
differences between the two
and know when it is appropriate to use
each kind of object and
this works in actor systems right and we
you know try to make sort of the same
decisions here
keep keep communication explicit so that
people can deal with things like latency
or failure
in a very explicit way right because the
idea is that you want to build something
on top of one of these frameworks
okay so that's sort of the motivation
behind or some of the design decisions
or sort of
the goals we we had when we started this
uh what does it look like
um so there are two
whoops two concepts right i think i've
already kind of mentioned them
uh one keep your data stationary and
immutable
two you have portable functions that you
move around you move those to the data
um and so we have this one thing called
a spore
excellent name right so i have to come
up with another great name actually
if anybody has a better idea please tell
me but uh we right now we're just
referring to these containers that hold
this immutable data
these data stores as silos for now until
we can think of something better
and we have these spores and the idea is
that that this whole model is based on
like
you know passing spores between these
container silo things
which hold the data or or encapsulate
the data basically
so let's first look at maybe what these
these silo things are
um kind of like a an actor you they come
in two parts
you have the thing itself that holds the
data the thing on the right
uh it's parameterized on the data that
it should be in caps or holding
and on the left you have this thing
called a siloref and it has
uh well two important methods
and you know much like an actor system
you have
a reference that you should be dealing
with locally that points to this thing
that should be
on some other machine and this handle
this this reference
is sort of like the workforce where you
do all the work on your distributed data
basically
uh or you you basically cue up
operations and things and you use this
to kind of like
asynchronously control what gets applied
to your your data
so the first uh sort of important method
uh is is an apply method right so i want
to i want to apply a function to my data
there are two functions here these four
things um and
and this the pi method returns another
silo ref
so well why is that um so
the reason for two spores is that uh if
you're going to be building a framework
on top of something like this some sort
of
function messaging kind of framework you
want to be able to
insert your sort of applicator or rather
your framework logic
uh in somehow right and so the the
the combinator like a map on a
distributed collections
would be one of those two spores and the
other would be the one that your user
passes you
if if there is one um
and this is i should you know very
important to notice that this thing that
this apply thing is actually lazy
what it does is it returns this silo ref
thing so it basically just
figures out everything that needs to do
to your remote piece of data
it has its functions it has kind of how
to get to it on some other machine
and it returns another reference which
represents the result
on some other remote machine whenever
that thing actually gets computed
uh so when that thing is later material
when the room the
the results silo thing the result piece
of data
is materialized somewhere else you have
a reference to it whenever it's it's
ready
and the other thing is is ascend so does
anybody know
what views are i don't know if you like
scholar or no scholar or or not
um and this is also in a lot of other
languages but we call them views
basically the idea is that you know you
you do a bunch of like lazy operations
and then eventually when you're ready to
to do the computation you can force it
so you can get rid of intermediate data
structures and whatnot and so
um the reason why there's an appliance
ascend is is is to have
sort of to be able to have like a a
a view like abstraction over this
distributed thing right
so the send is what is basically
equivalent to a force uh so i
i would then you know do some operations
on my piece of data and
maybe i have i end up with a few of
these silo refs you know
like a chain of them and then uh okay i
want result back now so i
i actually say okay framework send all
those functions that represent
you know operations to the data do it
and then give me the result
and so the future uh is what you know
asynchronously waits for
well you know is asynchronously computed
i should say uh so so this is this is
completed with the result that's
returned from
the the you know this chain of
operations that you set forth so
there so it's important to note that
this thing is eager it sends it actually
sends all that information that you you
collected and you
you keep in these silo refs to the
remote data
and it you know in an asynchronous
non-blocking kind of way it returns the
result to the local machine via the
future
okay um so let's just
look at it in picture form
so if you have this the silo ref thing
of t and the silo thing of t and you
know how your side of the ref knows how
to get
to or how to deliver something to your
to your silo
um basically the way that this works is
well
it sends some function this could
represent a function from t
to s over the over the wire to your to
your piece of data
and in the eager case it applies well
this is in time step here it would apply
it right you wind up with a
a uh like i mentioned this silo ref that
represents the transform data that
you know comes out of this one this
function application
and then you know whenever this this
piece of data is
is materialized uh your style ref gets
completed and pointed
i'm sorry ends up pointing directly to
that piece of did and it's just kind of
like actors when you're waiting for a
new actor to be spawned up or something
you can still send messages to this this
thing or use this thing in some way
and in the run time just kind of queues
messages and stuff so nothing gets lost
but sort of this is the the really basic
idea of how
how sort of you apply a function to a
piece of data and then what happens what
you how you get the result
and also important to note um the silo
things
uh aren't necessarily meant to be like
some huge piece of data
that you know like there's only one on
one machine
there can be several on one machine or
several different kinds of them
throughout
a cluster of different machines that's
similar to actors in that sense they can
they can hold something tiny or huge
it's up to you to decide and and so
that's kind of where we put the data
i'm going to give you a little kind of
like run down on on what these spore
things are
um without getting into way too much
detail
um this is sort of what they look like
in a basic way this is also uh at the
bottom of the screen there's a
an improvement the scholar improvement
proposal so you want to get into more
details there's a lot more details that
you could look up
look at um but this is the like the long
hand form
so um what is a spore it's supposed to
be a function right
but the idea is that the spore a spore
is a function and an environment
and it basically forces you to be
explicit with your environment and so
your environment is actually
represented by this thing called the
spore header so this is syntactic
basically
what it does is it forces you it just
doesn't compile if you don't actually
put the environment that you end up
referring to inside of your function
in the header right and this is like i
said this is the long hand form
there there's you can there's like a
literal form for writing these things
but this is
sort of how it looks uh in a macroscopic
sense
so there's the sport header thing at the
top i don't know if there's a oops nope
and then this this this function in here
uh this this
into whatever vowel result print line
this is the the actual closure and
everything inside of that closure
uh can only refer to the environment if
it refers to anything else you can't you
can't uh you can't
it doesn't it doesn't compile you can't
you can't serialize it basically
unless it's a top level object that's
publicly accessible on every machine
that's an exception
so if you're wondering about the
relationship between spores and closures
um so well i'm sorry it's four
guarantees
i should talk first the next slide is
what the the relationship
so everything that's captured uh is
declared in the spore header
which means that the initializers for
all of those things are called when the
thing when the spore is created
so uh that means that whatever you
capture cannot change over the execution
of anything it's it's basically
effectively immutable it like freezes
the environment as it is
and it basically you know you it doesn't
change over time
um and the relationship between spores
and closures
uh actually they have the exact same
evaluation semantics so if i go back
i'm sorry you can't really see that uh
if if i just remove this
this this foreheader thing here this
this block um
the evaluation semantics are exactly the
same like there's there's no i don't i
don't change how
how things get evaluated whoops
and they're also related because you can
you can write full function literals and
so long as as that function literal
um uh like you know abides by this the
rules
for it to be a spore uh you can pass
this to something that would expect a
score like something that you would you
know have some some
some method in an api that would expect
a function and maybe the the framework
author wants it to be a sport
it would basically do an implicit
conversion turn thing into a spore then
check the spore rules to make sure that
okay this thing
this thing does what it's supposed to do
doesn't have some crazy environment that
it tries to pull in
and and you know that that so so you can
convert basically between
uh normal function literals and spores
um
so if you walk away with anything about
spores what you should
keep in mind is basically that uh it's
got two huge benefits one is that the
environment is ex
is declared explicitly and it's it's
it's basically immutable it's fixed at
the time
that uh the the thing is is created the
support is created
and we can then also statically ensure
that everything that is captured
is serializable with this the
serialization framework
um and i mean there's there's uh
like if you want to know more there's a
paper about it but there's also
which is a lot nicer to read than a
paper is this this
scala improvement document the paper
actually includes an interesting
little type system that like i said
restricts what you like can restrict
certain types that you capture
so yeah so you can basically say i don't
want a user to pass a socket or a
an actor to my to my framework because i
can't serialize that
um so uh okay
fine i gave you the two pieces you have
these these immutable
things of data containers of data silo
thing
and you have have these spore things
right and the idea is that
uh you apply your your function
your spore thing to the the silo
of data right so maybe we can look at
kind of how that
how that works out i want to show you
um an example of what would happen
under the covers if somebody else has
kind of made a little distributed list
application on top of this
so basically what they did was we assume
for now
that somebody implemented a map method
or a map a map operation and a reduced
operation
and and as i mentioned earlier these
things are actually
implemented as spores and you'll see why
but this is this is because we end up
like i said passing them
around right so assuming that these
things are implemented for us
and assuming that what we want to do is
something
very like i said distributed list like
where you have a
little shards of a list all over on
different machines and
i want to do like a map on all the
pieces and then kind of keep track of
what the whole distributed thing is
and then maybe do another map and then a
reduce or something okay
so let's say that's what we want to do
let's kind of look at a cute little
illustration of
sort of what this would look like under
the covers
so you start out on the machine with the
local computation that actually kicks
off all the computation right
and you start off with the silo ref of
your original piece of data
so let's just say that our original
piece of data is a list of in right
so like i would have in this case i
would read this from some persistent
store
somewhere that i can always just like
reread it if i ever need it again
and i would basically start by calling
apply and passing the
the map function and what i whoops and
what
and the so basically the map function
and then the user passed function
this thing called f here so that would
be basically the function that somebody
would pass to a
to a the map higher order function right
and um what happens is okay a new a new
silo ref gets created and the new
siloref
contains all of the little pieces that
it needs
to uh evaluate
whatever this silo is on another machine
wherever it is
so i have everything i need to actually
get that result uh
remotely somewhere else associated with
the silo wrap that points to it
so uh and i also have a reference
to the piece of data that i came from so
the stylograph that i came from
so let's just say i want to do that map
another map and then a reduce
because why not it would all happen in
the same way
so you call the apply method and that
one is the the lazy one
so what i'm doing is i'm not actually
sending anything anywhere i'm just
kind of building a little computation
graph uh and then
when i deem ready to kick off this
computation i will do a force
so let's just say that well because i
want an actual result back from the
reduced
maybe it's you know in this case since
it's i'm doing a reduce on a list of
integers it's just one int
sure i want that back send it over the
wire send it back to me uh
at the root at the at the at the side
the silo rep that represents the reduce
the one
all the way to the right here uh is
where i would do
this send thing so that that that makes
that basically uh collects all of the
stuff all the pieces that i need
to do this computation and the idea is
that it would then send it over the wire
and kick that off right
so this is what things would look like
um
that original siloref would point to an
actual piece of data somewhere
uh of course it's a silo of listing
and then when uh this
send thing actually gets gets uh invoked
this is when like i said all of the the
functions and the pieces get sent
to the runtime that manages this silo
okay so you would send your function all
all of the functions or either either
all of the functions
or you could also do some sort of
function composition to get rid of
intermediate data structures like you
would do with a view
you have a choice as the the framework
builder to to do these things
whoops and this is basically what would
happen everything would then
start evaluating and then and you end up
with the same structure
you end up with a bunch of these silo
things
which contain references to the piece of
data that they came from
so what you end up having
oops sorry that happened too quickly
the silo thing on the very right here
the silo of int
represents as you can see the reduce
operator
and when that finishes its operation
this would then
return return its result back to
back to the silo ref that requested it
and it completes that future that i
showed you earlier
so the send the send method
has type future of t where in this case
it's future of int and it gets completed
with the result
of the reduce so
um you might ask then how
uh how exactly does that help fault
tolerance well
if you look at this again um this whole
thing whoops
let's keep doing right yeah if you look
at this whole thing
um it's it's you can actually
imagine this is a very simple case this
can easily branch out like i could
take this intermediate map where you
apply the f to it
and and uh maybe do a reduce there or i
can make basically a tree like data
structure
that represents all of the different
sort of computations that i do with
intermediate results
and you know this the structure would be
replicated on both
on both sides basically because you wind
up with the same structure and all the
functionality required
on both sides to basically run the
the whatever the map function plus the
user defined map
the user supplied function parameter
that you would give to the map
you have all of that so actually what
you end up having
is this persistent data structure uh
that you build up
oops and and so um
if you want your system to be fault
tolerant which means if something
crashes or fails you want to be able to
restart
something and be able to rebuild uh what
you lost
uh it's it's pretty easy actually given
the the structure and the way things
are are are built up to reconstruct
uh one of these silos because these
silos and these silo refs relate to each
other
uh like i said via this persistent data
structure you have like all you know you
have this tree like structure
and um if in like i said you have all of
the
the operations that you need to derive
the data that you are looking for as
your result
so to figure out how to
uh recompute what you had just lost all
you have to do is traverse your little
data structure
to complete uh your lineage which is
basically the the history or all the
operations that you ended up
doing on your on your original piece of
persistent data
and since this whole lineage thing is
composed of spores
uh it can be serialized uh so you can
either write this to disk
you can uh you know if you have two
machines running sort of
like like identical shards or sorry
identical jobs on on different
data shards uh you could just maybe have
one machine
you know pass to his neighbor the
lineage that he was working on right and
then
you could restart computation that way
so
uh just by design it's pretty simple to
to restart jobs so
to sort of summarize the these this
data whatever this data container silo
plus spores model that i call right now
function passing
all of these operate like all of this is
is is managed using a persistent data
structure and all of the operations
including
uh those provided by the framework
builders
uh are these are spores so that means
that they they can be serialized
uh and they can be you know like i said
persisted and used as some sort of
uh point to re or rather some sort of uh
functionality to rerun uh and as a
result of that like these two things
together make it a little bit easier to
to to you know recover from from
a failure somewhere because you don't
have to
to try and recreate some some state that
you've saved somewhere else
and maybe uh someone might you might ask
okay
well uh if i if i have
some way to send messages and i have
these four things it seems like sort of
uh the the what what you get from this
whole
this whole model is is the ability to
like i said send this functionality
around
so if you're just smart with it you know
couldn't you just send
spores between different actors or not
even actors but
whatever two different processes and
that's and i i
agree that you you can that's pretty
powerful already but
the way that this model is is built
because it's
you have this this persistent data
structure and you know
uh you don't have to worry about state
getting all messed up
you get a lot more extra sort of
benefits out of the box so the one thing
is that this
statelessness in these lineages you know
to simplify
uh like recovering from failures but
also
one thing i didn't really cover in
detail is is is
this deferred evaluation so like this
laziness idea so the idea that you can
kind of do like a distributed view
so if you go back to this example oh
wait yeah i shouldn't do this because
it's going to
do the whole thing again if you're if
you go back here
you and let's just say that each each of
these three pieces of
of of of uh resulting sort of data
these uh the results the the three new
silo things that you end up with
um you know like maybe since they
represent each maps
you could imagine that uh i would
compose the two functions that represent
these two intermediate
silos right so then i could get rid of
an intermediate data structure because
why traverse the whole data set twice
you can do things like this because you
know with the the apply
uh sort of send uh methods it's up to
the
the person who winds up uh building the
the framework
um yep
and and so that's sort of like the the
idea behind this um right now we're just
experimenting with it uh if you think
that you have
some situation or use case that i
couldn't handle uh
let us know because it's it's right now
it's a
it's an exercise we're we're trying to
push it and see see how far we can
we can take it how how annoying it gets
to actually implement
uh an interesting system on top of it
which is why sort of i'm playing with it
uh in the spark project
uh so if you have any thoughts or if you
want to to
you know like like let me know
that you have some some impossible thing
that i can't can't uh cover please tell
me
i'd love to hear it so that's it thank
you
if you have any questions
so sure i guess do you have any examples
of what you've been able to do with this
uh so right now i'm just
trying to right now so i'm just building
basically
i have two sort of applications that
i've been playing with and one is like
trying to build some spark like
framework on top of it or to insert it
into spark to see all the places that it
breaks or how annoying it gets
and then another thing is to try and do
some sort of streaming application so
streaming in that you know you have
small enough sort of batches small
kind of like silo things that collect
like you know small pieces of data and
then you
keep track of well yeah i mean a
streaming application
with small pieces of silo data um
uh so so no so um so the question was
how do you actually serialize the code
uh so in scala when you compile
an anonymous function you i'm sorry or a
function lateral or any sort of function
you wind up with a synthesized class so
you actually have a class that
represents that function
the problem is the thing that that
spores solve
is that you know this thing can you know
reference anything
it can have mutable uh reference like
you can have vars inside of it that you
can reassign
uh you can do all kinds of things inside
of this inside of this function that
just basically break all the time during
you know
at runtime so it's actually it's
actually a big problem for spark
um there a lot of people regularly run
into issues with it it's a very popular
question on their mailing list and they
have a special bike
byte code cleaning tool that clears out
any sort of outer references
to any other object so that like even if
you wanted to logically reference
something over you know in somewhere
other place it just gets nulled out so
you have to figure that out yourself
so it's actually a real problem that
they they they face
i mean a silo is just a piece of data
and it's the same as if you do a
reduction like on a list
so you actually like you actually
implement that in in
the function that you pass to it right
so i have i have the type
i have a list and then i call reduce on
it i know that i can can call reduce on
a list and i have the function
that you want to pass to that reduce so
it's all the same as normal
several silos that you need to reduce
over it so then you need to have some
sort of reduction tree that you build up
right
and that's that's something that you
build and then the communication sort of
of the like so you build yourself you
figure out yourself as a framework
builder like i said i didn't really show
you how how to build a
the logic that you would like as
somebody who wanted to build like a
spark like abstraction
i didn't give you like that
implementation the the map of the reduce
um but the idea is that in those
functions that
all you would be doing really is the
communication so you would be figuring
out the hierarchy of things like on some
machine on the machine that does the
the the master machine that dispatches
all the jobs uh you would figure out
sort of
like the hierarchy of all the other
machines and you would figure out um
you know who does what and then what you
actually send to it
is is calls to local classes uh to
actually do that reduced locally
and then you know aggregating all the
futures that you wind up getting back is
something that you as i said
the framework builder implement yourself
you just make sure that what you pass is
just a a spore to each individual
machine that represents the logic to be
calling on that
individual node if that's clear i hope
that's clear
uh okay um i guess yeah
uh that's a good question so they're
serializable
actually i i don't see why you couldn't
i don't know
what horrible thing could happen if one
of your users had somehow a reference to
one of your
distributed pieces of data uh i haven't
i haven't thought about it but
right now i don't see any restriction
against it
yep
uh so spark actually does so this is
this this is
basically um so the question right to
repeat the question
how does this differ from from spark
rdds uh so this is basically just like a
little message passing
thing where we're passing function it's
just a little way to move data
i'm sorry functions to data it spark
does 10
zillion more things it also doesn't do
things internally in a very
well typed way everything inside of
spark is any
so it's actually kind of hard to figure
out what's even happening when there are
errors inside
um and so really the what this is is a
super like lightweight idea
uh that sort of like sort of represents
the the basic sort of functioning of
what spark does
which is it has mutable data it applies
a function gets a new piece of immutable
data
and then you know same lineage idea
where you can recover
it does all that but in a lightweight
way where you don't have to actually
have some huge distributed data set you
can do anything you want with it i can
coordinate
between two different data stores i
don't have to have a distributed
collections abstraction built on top of
it
it's like something that somebody else
can pick up and sort of uh benefit from
some of the sort of
same good design decisions that mate
made when he when he designed spark in
the first
place
so how like how do you mean how do you
know when a node crashes
how do you synchronize nodes so if you
know a node crashed
um you know it's so it's up to you to
duplicate
these lineages if you don't uh
then and you have one node then you lose
your one node and
that's it but the idea is that you
should have
this should if you are you know having
multiple machines you should have this
lineage replicated you can ask a
neighbor
you can save it to disk and you can look
it up again and reuse it and restart the
whole thing
so you should have some persistent store
like like something that you read from
s3
or some piece of data that you know how
to get at again and then you have your
all the the operations that you've
called on that data and you can just
replay them
is that the question that you asked okay
cool
yep
maybe it could have composed them or
um something i it's actually for the
sake of abstraction
um because right now like i said the use
cases that i'm focusing on that sort of
really fit this model really well
are situations where you have a bunch of
data and
uh you're trying to basically coordinate
a bunch of machines
and do some kind of batch processing or
uh streaming thing
um and
in order to abstract over this thing uh
it's
it's really hard to insert your own
functionality that doesn't have state
how do i how do i like implement the map
without state
and the way to do that is to have some
function that represents like whatever
functionality you're trying to actually
implement in your system uh
and we do it like in this this sport way
so you're forced to write it in a
stateless way
and and you know then whatever the user
passes to which also abides by the same
restrictions
yep so see you're talking about
like having the opportunity to do
composition on the client side
and then but then on the server side
you may want to do decomposition right
so do like mapping here on some servers
uh do re reduction on other servers
so how do you do it like do you provide
this information uh this like uh
opportunity it reminds me like modeling
lambda in a bike
yeah so like the let me try to
you can correct me if i have your
question wrong um but you're asking
it's mostly about is it about like the
laziness like reduced like having um
like this view thing where i can
on this on the well on the the local
side on the side that sends the
the the command to do something to the
data on that side i can like
you know do like this this fusion or get
rid of these intermediate data
structures right you're saying why can't
you also have that ability on the data
side right
is that what you're asking no i was
talking about rather like those
functions
right oh okay yeah
oh to decompose uh yeah actually i
haven't thought about i haven't thought
about wanting to decompose i don't know
what situation where you would want to
decompose
uh that's a good question i haven't i
haven't deeply considered it
yep
like uh so i don't completely understand
the question i
understand that you're saying there's
this one scenario where you have like
you know super compute intensive thing
like one of these silo things with
a bunch of data then you have other
scenarios where you could have little
pieces of data
but i don't what do you mean exactly
like like is there some intuition for
performance trade-offs um
yeah actually like it kind of gets it's
very funny because it gets kind of
more future like or something as the
data gets smaller
right uh and then so you can have a lot
more of these things and then they can
be doing all kinds of
you know more messaging or whatever
because that's like the thing that
they're doing that's expensive
or you could have the larger one that
does you know like
churning through some data set and the
latency is not as important
um i i don't i don't have much to say
but
you know that's a like a decision of the
application or rather the framework
developer to try and
sort of optimize those two things but
the whole point is that like they have
the ability to decide
how big their data is that they store in
these little things so if you have lots
of little small pieces of data perhaps
try not to communicate too much if you
have a big piece of data who cares how
much you communicate just get the job
done i guess and
that would be who who builds the
framework i guess
yep um
nope no um so i don't i don't prevent
side effects
at all like we don't have any way to do
that so there's nothing i can really do
however side effecting like i i alluded
to is good sometimes like i need to log
maybe you know so yeah it would be nice
to have
things be completely fully pure but
there are practical reasons especially
in the distributed system that you do
kind of want some
sort of side effecting operation if you
have a thing that actually has to run
then
logging is good exceptions could be good
you know
so i don't stop those because they're
practical
and i can't anyway
yep
sure yeah like one that represents
transformation that happened yep
that's the question okay
i actually i'm three minutes over time
so if there's any other questions
i can take them otherwise i think that's
it